now the World Health Organization says
Russia has carried out the biggest
attack on Health Care on European soil
since World War II and it's left
millions of ukrainians facing a
life-threatening situation this winter
the who's head in Europe hunt Kluger
said that freezing temperatures combined
with a health system badly damaged in
Russia by in Russian missile attacks in
the winter will be about survival
it's zero degrees Celsius as night falls
in her Zone
and edina's home plunges into darkness
turning on the stove is the only way to
keep the family warm
in the evening when it's dark and cold
my daughter becomes nervous she's used
to light but it's constantly dark now
Russia's missile attacks on Ukraine's
power Graves and other energy
infrastructures means millions of
ukrainians will Brave a harsh winter
without proper Heating
but that's not the only worry
so much
the who says it has documented more than
700 attacks on health infrastructure
since Russia's Invasion began in late
February
hundreds of damaged hospitals lack basic
facilities Like Water and Power
and in their current state the health
care units cannot fully support the
people
this winter will be life-threatening for
millions of people in Ukraine the
devastating energy crisis the deepening
Mental Health Emergency
constraints on humanitarian access and
the risk of viral infections
will make this winter a formidable test
for the Ukraine health system and the
Ukraine people
but also for the world and its
commitment to support Ukraine
to ease pressure on energy resources
authorities in health
urge people to leave the region if they
can
get more from DW correspondent to Nick
Conley who's in the Ukrainian Capital
welcome Nick can you give us a sense of
the state of health facilities there
after these devastating attacks
I think Phil it's really difficult to
kind of divide up Health from all the
other services here in Ukraine now here
in the capital of Kiev where I am now
things are still working it can kind of
you can even for a moment forget the war
if you kind of don't pay attention to
the news and don't happen to be near a
place that's been affected by drones or
bombing or some other kind of attacks
but this is a country where the energy
infrastructure by the emission of the
Ukrainian government has been destroyed
to about a quarter or a third of its
pre-war state where millions of people
have left including a disproportionate
number of women who are very
overrepresented in the medical sphere
doctors nurses administrators and you
know those two factors together you're
having you know hospitals that are
living off generators where they don't
always know where the next canister of
diesel is coming from where they will
get you know more complicated medicines
where they will get things like oxygen
supplies if roads and infrastructure are
destroyed and you know lots of people
who had previously have been organizing
all these kind of logistics that are
crucial for modern medicine those people
are no longer there or fighting in this
war so it is kind of a perfect storm
lots of different things coming at the
same time and a country that is really
struggling to basically survive these
constant Russian attacks on civilian
infrastructure for now the Ukrainian
government is carrying on is paying
wages it is able to finance the purchase
of supplies with help from Western
countries who have been putting in
billions of euros and dollars into
Ukrainian government coffers but there
is a sense that now after almost a year
of war that kind of initial resilience
is now being chipped away at and that
you know if more attacks come more
attacks on the energy Supply if we have
more direct attacks on transport
infrastructure then you know we could
actually see a real decrease in the
ability of the Ukrainian government to
provide some kind of rudimentary Medical
Services to its population right so
daily life in some of these worsted
areas it sounds like it's just grim
yeah I mean you have people who have
been without Maine's power for you know
the best part of eight months since the
War Began people who are you know going
into the fields around them trying to
look for firewood wondering whether
there are mines in those uh kind of
hedgerows in the forests where they're
looking firewood making that calculation
whether it's worth taking those risks to
get some wood to you know heat a stove
and make some warm food or to best stay
you know in your darkened house or in
your Cellar waiting for the shelling to
end places like bakmud and dignetsk
region which are seeing some of the
worst fighting now lots of people have
left and they're being called on by the
Ukrainian government to get out while
they still can but this has been the
pattern all through this war that people
normally you know the vast majority of
people do not want to leave especially
older people refuse to leave until often
enough it's too late and then when they
do want to go when the shooting is just
unbearably close often their evacuation
is very dangerous and then other people
are put at risk trying to get these
people out so it's a very difficult
situation and one that's likely to get a
lot worse before it gets better we heard
yesterday from the people in charge of
Ukraine's energy system that if things
even if there were no further major
attacks by the Russians on Ukraine's
energy Supply ukrainians will be living
with basically chaotic energy blackouts
till the spring that's you know best
case scenario but I think no one here
believes that the Russians are anywhere
close to ending those attacks and
seemingly the Russian tactics are
increasingly to attack the logistics and
the kind of Hinterland of Ukraine given
how badly they're doing on the
battlefield
thank you for that Nick Nick Connelly
and Keith
now in the Ukraine against the odds the
Ukrainian National Railway has continued
running throughout the war as trains
have played a crucial role in helping
people flee the conflict but when Russia
occupied parts of Southern Ukraine eight
months ago some of those trains stopped
now that Hassan has been liberated The
Rail Link has been restored DW's young
Philip Schultz joined passengers on the
train to Hassan as they had to be
reunited with their loved ones
a famous Harrison band in Kiev station
playing for fellow carsonite's returning
for the first time
tonight train 102 is heading to the
liberated South
painted by artists it's dubbed the train
to Victory each wagon representing an
occupied territory
ludmila's daughter helps her with her
bag everyone is Keen to get aboard the
Train's about to take them all home
they called me yesterday while I was at
work they told me the first train would
leave tonight I can't describe how that
made me feel
the Ukrainian Railway system has become
a surprise star of the war trains have
evacuated tens of thousands of people
from the fighting and kept the country
running operators see nine out of 10
trains are still on time
at first everyone was afraid now we just
do our jobs
everything's calm everything's okay
Daybreak as we approached Harrison
Don shows what the war has done
Ludmila fled just after the War Began
her husband stayed today they'll see
each other again for the first time
but I'm so full of emotions I can't
believe I'm on a train back home but I
left the children in Kiev I'm still a
bit worried about the situation but I
know things are getting better
crowds await to see their City again
joined to the rest of the country
yet in this moment for lubmilla and
mikola it's just them
to be honest I didn't want her to come
back just yet I think it's still too
dangerous but this is her home and her
mother lives here that's how it is
her personal reunion is part of an
international story Ludmila enters a
City without power dependent on aid but
she's home
Maria avdiva is a security analyst and
research director at the European expert
Association that's a think tank focusing
on the future of Ukraine and she told me
about her recent visit to Hassan when I
spoke to her earlier
the people in Hearthstone are happy
because of the Liberation but the
hardships there are going through are
very big because the city still doesn't
have electricity uh water supply because
pumps run on electricity gas supply the
supermarkets only just opened so the the
in the cold months that Ukraine faces it
will be very difficult for people to
continue uh living there and we see that
Russia doesn't stop the attacks on the
city just yesterday there was an attack
on civilian buildings residential area
one of the missiles he'd actually the
apartment for people who are injured and
one person later on died in the hospital
so it sounds like conditions are really
quite tough but for the civilians there
is there a sense of freedom is there a
sense of great change
absolutely people tell me uh that they
now can breathe freely because they said
that under the Russian occupation they
tried not to go out they saw themselves
people uh with the black backs on their
heads being taken to the prisons torture
they heard screams so they started to
stay at home and if they needed to go
out it was for a quick something outside
and now when Ukraine is back they were a
Ukrainian Flags this uh feeling of great
patriotism is everywhere and people are
smiling their waving hands so you feel
this feeling of Victory everywhere in
the streets of Carson where you
mentioned it earlier the issue that
there is no water no electricity now the
World Health Organization is warning
that the lives of millions are
threatened in Ukraine because of the
Russian attacks both on energy
infrastructure and on Health Facilities
do you think that the incredible resolve
we've seen amongst the Ukrainian
population do you think that the the
cold
might wear them down this winter
people are getting prepared so uh
Russians tactics is now every week they
fire
hundreds of missiles on Ukraine last
time it was more than 90 trying to hit
every piece of energy and electricity
infrastructure now in Odessa there is no
power again there are power shutdowns
everywhere throughout the country in a
lot of smaller settlements and Villages
around mikolai and her son there is
still no power and there is no uh in the
upcoming weeks probably there it won't
be restored because before uh retreating
a Russian Russian troops uh exploded
everything so this will be very
difficult but people are prepared for
this a lot of them both generators the
government advises if they can move to a
safer places do that so people are
trying to a brace for this upcoming
winter months but everyone understands
that it will be very difficult and the
hospitals are running on generators so
hospitals did it before they bought
enough generators but of course it's all
the time Russia is trying to hit more
and more civilian infrastructure objects
a really really difficult situation
Maria advada from the European expert
Association thank you so much for your
time